حياكم الله نحو 16 الف قتيل في سوريا
وتركيا وفجاعه الزلزال متواصله حصيله
الضحايا بارتفاع مستمر والامال بالعثور
على ناجينا تتضاءل بعد دخول الماساه يومها
الرابع فيما تزداد معاناه المنكوبين معكم
على مدار الساعه في تغطيه متواصله لهذا
الحدث الجلل نتابع جدا ماساوي نحن بحاجه
يعني ماسه لتدخلني
افهم اكثر
الجهود
للمتطوعين الناس في هذه المنطقه هل
استطاعوا ايجاد ثغرات في تلك المباني
المتهالكه والتي هذا الركام المتكدس فوق
تلك الاجساد المحاصره تحت
نعم استاذي لو وجود الناس والاهالي في في
مساعده بعض الناجين لم يخرج احد لم ينجو
احد من السوريين تحت لهذه الانقاض يعني
الدفاع المدني الاهالي
لحظه بلحظه اي صوت يسمعونه يحاولون قدر
الامكان اخراجه ولكن في كثير من الناس في
معاهم في معاهم يعني اشخاص مدربين ام هي
جهود يعني تلقائيه فقط
يحاولون رفع على انقاذ دونما خطه من اشخاص
مدربين
نحن نحن لا يوجد لدينا اي شيء يعني لا
يوجد لدينا ناس مدربين على هذا الامر يعني
في كثير من الوفيات وجدوها يعني ممكن
تاذت اكثر في سحب الجثه تاذت اكثر في سحب
الطفل انا بس اذكر لك احدى القصص
في سحب احد الاطفال قال الطفل
المنقذ قلو لو انك بس يعني مسبق خمس ساعات
امي كانت عايشه
احنا نسمع ناس عم تنادينا ونحن قادرين انه
نوصلهم الوضع جدا جدا كارثي يعني يعني دون
جدوى يعني نحن يعني
صدقا لا نستطيع وصف شعورنا لمن لمن نسمع
طفل او امراه تصرخ وانت لا تستطيع ان تقدم
شيء
يعني تسمعون هذه الاصوات تسمعون كيف
تتعامل او يتعامل المتطوعون لاخراجهم
في في اصوات لحد الان موجوده تحت المقاض
ولكن المسافات بعيده بين الصوت
والفرق لانقاذ فتحتاج مثلا الاسقف منهاره
مثلا ثلاث اربع اسقفه فوق راس
الناجي فيحتاج صعوبه جدا في اخراجها هؤلاء
الناجين في منهم قد فارق الحياه في اخر
لحظات لم يستطع احد الوصول اليه
نحن لحد هذه اللحظات موجود عندنا ناجين
تحت الانقاض ولكن لا نستطيع الدخول اليهم
لا نستطيع الوصول اليهم يعني قليل جدا ما
وصلنا الى بعض الاطفال حتى
سيدي الاطفال بصراحه استخراجهم صار اسهل
من استخراج الرجل الكبير لان الطفل ممكن
يكون عالق في زاويه ما نستطيع الدخول
اليها نخرج ولكن الرجل مثلا بيكون كبير
يكون نازل عليه الحيطان الجدران السقف لا
يستطيع الخروج
حتى المعدات المعدات
تؤذي لانه ما هي ما هي اختصاصها انه تسحب
السقف
طيب الناس اللي اللي نجوا من هذا الزلزال
ما هي اوضاعهم الانسانيه في جنديرس
بالنسبه للناس اللي نجوا
الاوضاع الانسانيه جدا جدا سيئه يعني تخيل
انه الاطفال بحاجه الى حليب الاطفال بحاجه
الى مستلزماتهم لا يوجد مستلزمات الاهالي
بحاجه الى
غطاء انه يعني الاهالي اول يومين بتنام في
العراء في العراء في البرد نحن اليوم
الحراره عندنا ناقص خمسه يعني جدا جدا
الجو بارد على الاهالي الناس بحاجه ماسه
لمساعدات انسانيه لاكل لدواء
لمعدات طبيه
اغلب المرضى اغلب الاطفال لا يوجد لديهم
اعانات
طيب رمضان بودي انا اتساءل انه هناك ايضا
عبر معبر باب الهوى يقال ان في صهاريج
وقود دخلت هل وصل الى جندير الشيء من هذه
الصهاريج بالنسبه الى جنديرس لم يدخل
بالنسبه الى جنديرس لم يدخل اليها لحد
الان اي مساعدات من خارج سوريا كلها
مساعدات محليه الاهالي في الريف الشمالي
من اتى بنفسه لمساعده اهالي جنديرس من
ارسل لنا حرامات من ارسل لنا يعني نحن
نشكر الداخل السوري الوحيد اللي حاول بشتى
الوسائل ان يقف مع اهله في جنديرس ولكن
هذا الامر لا نستطيع تغطيته قلت لك يعني
بس بجنديرس في اكثر من 115 الف نسمه
ساكنين هاي المدينه
جدا جدا ضخمه في عدد السكان والابنيه
80% او
90% من جنديرس اصبحت ركام
والباقي من المنازل
مصدع لا يصلح للسكن المستشفيات ما هو وضع
المستشفيات الجرحى
هالجراحهم خطيره هل هناك ايضا ربما نزوح
من الاهالي من ليس لديهم ماوى في جنديرس
الى اماكن اخرى
بالنسبه للمستشفيات فهي مليئه بالجرحى
مليئه بالمصابين مليئه
بالجثث الجثث في المداخل المشافي الوضع
جدا جدا سيء استاذ بالنسبه للمشاكل حتى
المشافي تستقبل الحالات الحرجه جدا لا
تستطيع ان تستقبل الحالات الباري البارده
يعني الطفل ياتي يضمدونه ويرسلونه الى
اهله انا امبارح زرت احد الناجين كان
مكسوره عظم الرقبه
لم يستطيع البقاء في المشفى فقد اخرجوه
قالوا له انه يوجد ناس امس بالحاجه انهم
يكونوا في المشفى فخرجوه فتخيل انه
غير قادر انه حدا يرسل له دواء يعني صار
يترجاني انه اخي بس بدي حدا يجي يداويني
حدا يعطيني ادويه مسكنات جدا يعني الوضع
سيء بالنسبه
المواد الطبيه في جنديرس
شكرا جزيلا رمضان سليمان الصحفي من ريفي
حلب الشمالي
لم تقف الكارثه الطبيعيه في تركيا وسوريا
على الهزه الشديده التي ضربت المنطقه بل
كانت الهزات الارتداديه التي نجمت مثل رعب
كبير بين السكان الذين
بقيوا خارج منازلهم تحسبا لتلك الهزات
الهزات الارتداديه سلسله من الزلازل تحدث
بعض الصدمه الرئيسيه الاكبر على الصدع بين
الصفائح التكتونيه تحدث بالقرب من الصدعم
بحسب العلماء حيث حدثت الصدمه الرئيسيه هي
جزء من عمليه اعاده التعديل بعد الانزلاق
الرئيسي في الصدع بين الصفائح
تنتج عن التغيير المفاجئ في الاجهاد الذي
يحدث داخل وبين الصخور
ليس لها عدد محدد الا ان تواترها ينخفض مع
الوقت تستمر حتى ايام او اشهر او سنوات
بعد الهزه الاساسيه تم تسجيل اقوى هزه
ارتداديه بعد الزلزال الذي ضربت تركيا
وسوريا على انها زلزال بقوه 7.5 درجه
وتلتها مئات الهزات الارتداديه في المنطقه
كنا نياما عند حدوث الزلزال فجاه بدات
الاهتزازات على هذه الحاله استيقظنا احتضن
اطفالنا وقمنا بالركض ونحن ندعو الله كانت
الاهتزازات لا تنتهي حقيقه شيء يصعب شرحه
الله لا يبتلي احدا بهذا المصاب عندما
غادرنا البناء بدات الهزات الارتداديه بعد
عده دقائق حينها ركضنا في الشارع وكان
الجميع في حاله هلعه كان شعورا سيئا
للغايه
عندما جلبت اقربائي من منطقه نورداك في
ولايه غاز عنتاب بعد حدوث الزلزال كان
امامنا ثلاث حافلات تقل الجيش والشرطه كان
هناك هطول الامطار والثلوج لذلك ساعدونا
في الوصول استغرق الطريق 16 ساعه علما انه
يستغرق عاده ساعتين
وجئت لمساعده اصدقائي هنا وانقاذ الناس
ابني ايضا جاء معي للمساعده وهو يعمل مع
الاوراق المتطوعين انا اسكن في الطابق
الاول عند حدوث الزلزال خرجنا الى الشارع
بسرعه في منطقه
مشهدا مخيفا
والد زوجه طيفيفون اي دوغان وزوجته عائشه
واولادهما ثلاثه كانوا يعيشون في هذا
المبنى وجميعهم تحت الانقاض حاليا لم
نستطع الوصول اليهم حتى اللحظه ما تزال
اعمال الانقاذ مستمره ونحن لم نفقد الامل
بعد
في مدينه حارم شمال ادلب والتي تعد من
اكبر المناطق التضررا جراء الزلزال تواصل
فرق الانقاذ بحثها عنا جينا بين الانقاض
[موسيقى]
تتدرب بقى المعلومات بخصوص معبر باب الهوى
ورغم ما تؤكده تركيا والامم المتحده من
تضرر الطرق المؤديه اليه الا ان وكاله
الانباء الفرنسيه وشهود عيان رصدوا عمل
المعبر بشكل طبيعي معبر يستقبل جثث
السوريين فقط حتى الان دون وصول اي
مساعدات
[موسيقى]
لا صوت يعلو فوق صوت اهات السوريين في
معبر باب الهوى وفي كل جغرافيا سوريا
المكان لا يتسع سوى لبكاء ونحب الاحياء
وهم يستقبلون جثث امواتهم
الطرق سالكه فقط لنقل من فارق الحياه اما
من نجا من الكارثه ربما لن ينجوا من
تبعاتها
لا مساعدات لا فرق انقاذ تصل رقعه الشمال
السوري الذي مزقته الحرب قبل ان تعبث به
اقدار الطبيعه
المعلومات بخصوص نقل المساعدات عبر المنفذ
متضاربه منظمات الاغاثه التابعه للامم
المتحده تؤكد تضرر الطرق المؤديه الى
المعبر رغم وجود مستودعات اغاثه اما وكاله
الانباء الفرنسيه وشهود عيان فقد رصدوا
عمل المعبر بشكل طبيعي ليس لنقل المساعدات
بل لنقل جثث السوريين لدفنهم تحت تراب
الوطن
هربوا من طيران بشار الاسد لتركيا
لكن قضاء الله فوق كل شيء ونحن راضيين
بقضاء الله
[موسيقى]
في انتظار ما ستجود عليهم الانسانيه من
مساعده انسانيه السوريون يواصلون مواجهه
الماساه دون سنه حتى الان
ماساه تتفقم في وقت تؤكد الامم المتحده ان
عمليه البحث والانقاذ لا تغطي سوى خمسه في
المئه من المواقع المتضرره بالشمال السوري
ولكم ان تتخيلوا حجم الكارثه
بلال الوجداني العربيه
الانسان اولا والسياسه جانبا في شمال غرب
سوريا
الامم المتحده دعت الى تسهيل ايصال
المساعدات الى المناطق الخاضعه لسيطره
فصائل المعارضه في سوريا
والمنكوبه بفعل الزلزال
المساعدات الانسانيه المخصصه لشمال غرب
سوريا تعبر من تركيا عبر باب الهوى الذي
تضرر جراء الزلزال
ضعوا السياسه جانبا ودعونا نقوم بعملنا
الانساني اذ لا يمكننا تحمل الانتظار
الدمار في حلب وحمص واللاذقيه وفي شمال
غرب البلاد هائل وعلينا الوصول الى هناك
من اجل تقييمه
نامل في استئناف نقل المساعدات وان نكون
قادرين على عبور الحدود يوم الخميس
والشاحنه جاهزه للمغادره
انها ازمه فوق ازمه وليس هناك معدات للبحث
والانقاذ ولا معدات طبيه ولا ادويه كافيه
هذا ما دعا اليه المنسق المقيم للامم
المتحده في سوريا
المصطفى بن لمليح
قبل الزلزال كانت غالبيه السكان بحاجه الى
مساعدات انسانيه والكارثه الاخيره
راكمت ماساه فوق الاخرى
معنى من القاهره المديره المرصده سوري
لحقوق الانسان رامي عبد الرحمن سيد رامي
اهلا بك هل مناجينا
اعداد ربما وحصيله تكسر حركه عداد الموتى
المتزايد
نعم والمشاكل مستمره صباح الخير حقيقه
الامر يعني نبدا من المعبر حتى اللحظه لم
تدخل اي قافله لا خلينا من المعبر هل من
حصيله اوليه على الاقل خلينا نتكلم راح
افرد للمعبر محور اذا تكرمت استاذ رامي
تمام في مناطق ادلب العدد حتى اللحظه يعني
ارتفع ببضعه عشرات وليس بالمئات حتى
اللحظه
ارتفع
يوم امس حوالي ثلاثين في مناطق النظام
ومناطق المعارضه الى نحو
3540 في المنطقه لكن ايضا هناك في الحي
المشارقه في حلب جرى اخراجين من تحت
الانقاذ ايضا في محاوله واستماته من كل
فرق الدفاع المدني لاخراج ناجين من تحت
الانقاذ حقيقه الامر
لماذا المعبر لا اتحدث عن المعبر كمبر
نتحدث عن مساعدات لمساعده فرق الانقاذ
لمحاوله العثور على رجلين هناك موجوده في
حال نعم في جنديرس كارثه
حتى اللحظه فرق الانقاذ غير قادره حقيقه
الامر امكانيات بسيطه
وكارثه كبيره لذلك اقول بان يعني يجب ان
تدخل الفرق قبل شوي ايضا كان معي صحفي من
جنديرس يقول حتى هي مشفره انقاذ هي جهود
متطوعين
تمام تماما يعني انا اتحدث مع متطوع يا
سيدي الكريم هو عامل في المرصد قال انا
ذاهب من اجل المساعده يعني طيب هذا هذا
يدفعني الى الى سؤال يعني بين بين
الامم المتحده وتركيا التي تقول ان المعبر
لا يعمل والطرق او الطرق المؤديه اليه
تصعب مهمه الوصول هناك حديث عن انه تسع
صهاريج يوم امس دخلت الى الداخل السوري
اضافه في المقام الاول الى جثه السوريين
الذين
قتلوا نتيجه هذا الزلزال يعني الانسان
اولا ام السياسه
جانبا هذه قاعده لا تطبق في سوريا لماذا
لان الشعب السوري هو مغيب بالنسبه للامم
المتحده على الانسانيه نعم في الكلام
والحديث نقول الانسان والسوري والجبه
المستعد للشعب السوري ولكن شاهدنا وقلنا
على العربيه والحدث شاهدنا بالصوت والصوره
بان الجثث السوريين تدخل من تركيا الى
داخل الاراضي السوريه قلتها امس وامس
الاول بان زريعه المعبر لا يعمل سريعه
بان هناك يعني الطرق متضرره كيف تصل
سيارات الاسعاف وتدخل
من معبر باب الهواء معبر باب السلامه معبر
الراعي جميع المعابر يعني ممكن ان تعمل
وان تدخل مساعدات الى الاراضي السوريه
يعني هنا الامر بالنسبه للامم المتحده
تقول باننا يجب ان يكون هناك تفاهمات طيب
طائرات وصلت الى مطار حلب نعم طائرات وصلت
الى مطار دمشق نعم هذه الطائرات يعني الا
يوجد فيها امكانيه لدخول مساعدات باتجاه
مناطق ايضا شمال غرب سوريا مناطق شمال غلب
سوريا بقعه جغرافيه صغيره يوجد فيها كارثه
ثريه حقيقيه يقولون بان حتى اللحظه الفرق
عملت مع جزء بسيط من الكارثه نعم جزء بسيط
من الكارثه والاعداد هي هائله
من حجم الكارثه وفق الامم المتحده
الامم المتحده تتحدث بهذه الطريقه ماذا
عليه على عاملين على الارض عندما انت تاتي
بثائق يعني سائق جرافه يريد ان يساعد برفع
الانقاذ هل س فهو رغم امكانيته هو قادر
على العمل كمنقف اذا ما رفع يعني الركام
وانهار الركاب على رؤوس الذين هم تحت
الانقاذ مستحمل المسؤوليه الامم المتحده
ايضا عن سيدنا الكريم مساعدات انسانيه
للذين يعني باتوا في الشوارع في بعض
الملاجئ هذه كارثه حقيقيه حتى يا سيدي في
مناطق النصاب دقيقه دقيقه في مناطق النفاق
لن تصل المساعدات ايضا الى مستحقيها في
مناطق النظام ما بالك في مناطق سيطره
المعارضه طيب ليش ما تصل لماذا لا تصل
نريد ان نقول للامام السوري يعني انت تصل
الطائره الى مطار حلب وهل هناك في احياء
حلب من يحتاجون الى هذه المساعده اين تذهب
المساعدات يعني يعني يا بشار الاسد في
اللاذقيه يا اخي لا نريد ان نقولها حلا في
ممكن يرد عليكم ويقول لك انه في في دمار
في حلب ايضا هذه المناطق متضرره
يعني في الشيخ مقصود لا تصل المساعدات
المساعدات في احياء حلب الشرقيه لا تصل
مساعدات في بعض قرى اللاذقيه لا تصل
المساعدات في جبل جميعها مساعدات اهليه
حتى اللحظات وقيل بان مساعدات الوقت لتصرف
مساعدات ابناء الشعب السوري يفتحون
منازلهم لكل من تضرر بهذه الكارثه رغم
اننا نعلم ما قبل الكارثه ما قبل هذه
الكارثه الكبرى كان السوريه في حاله مزريه
الان هناك طائرات تصل من دول عربيه الى
مطارات اللاذقيه مطارات حلب يجب ان تذهب
المساعدات ويجب ان تدخل
بعض الدول بعض السيد رامي بعض الدول اليوم
لا تريد العمل مع المعارضه او المناطق
التي تقع تحت سيطره المعارضه هي تريد عن
طريق الامم المتحده حتى ان تقدم هذه
المساعدات ولكن عن طريق الامم المتحده
بالتفاهم مع النظام السوريه تم توزيع هذه
المساعدات
يا سيدي معارضه
نحن في مجال الان معارضه ونظامها
المضحك اكثر
يعني الحكومه المؤقته لعبد الرحمن مصطفى
جنديرس يوجد فيها مئات المنازل المهمه انس
عبد الرحمن مصطفى في جاكيته في منطقه
بعيده عن جنديرس يتحدث عن المساعدات
الاداره الذاتيه تريد تقييم ادخال
المساعدات الى هذه المنطقه تمنع من قبل
الحكومه المؤقته بسبب السياسه لذلك نقول
باننا يجب ان نبتعد عن السياسه الاولى
هناك ناس الان تحت الانقاذ هناك ناس في
الشوارع هناك برد طار هناك من يحتاج الى
يعني الى بطانيه من اجل ان يشعر بالدفع
هناك من يحتاج الى الطعام من اجل ان يشعر
بانه لا يعني تدمر مثله فقد احبائه وهو
غير قادر على الاستمرار في الحياه طيب
يعني اليوم المنسق المقيم للامم المتحده
في سوريا يدعو الى يعني هذه المساعدات لكن
ايضا تركيا
المتحده تقول بانه الطريق الى معبر باب
الهوى صعب الوصول اليها هناك ايضا من يقول
انا اتحدث عن مثلا الجرافات الكبيره
المعدات الكبيره التي تساهم في عمليه
الانقاذ هناك من يقول بانه هذه المعدات
الكبيره من الصعوبه ان تصل في في ظل هكذا
طرق غير صالحه لمرورها هذه المركبات
الكبيره عليها نعم نعم يعني من يقوم
بارسال الدبابات عبر الطائرات هو غير قادر
يقول اليات رفع ثقيله ومساعده السوريين هل
الاليات الثقيله اخراج الجسامين ام يجب ان
تصل اليات الثقيله لمساعده من هم تحت
الانقاذ قد يقولون على قيد الحياه وحماهم
الله من الموت الان لذلك اقول بان هناك
نفاق دولي مع الازمه الانسانيه
ظهر النفاق الدولي الجلي الان بان لا يوجد
انسانيه اقله ان اتحدث في سوريا مساعدات
نعم من الدول العربيه لكن نريدها من
الاعداد ان تصل الى ابناء الشعب السوري
الذين يعيشون الكارثه اداره الكوارث
التركيه تقول ارتفاع حصيل الضحايا الزلزال
الى 12 الفا وثمانمائه وسبعين قتيلا
واصابه نحو 63 الف شخص انت قلت قبل قليل
بانه الحصيله حتى الان 3000
وخمسمائه واربعين
قتيل جراء هذا الزلزال سيد رامي ام هناك
رقم متزايد اكثر من هذا الرقم
الرقم الحقيقي هو اكبر من هذا الرقم ابن
كثير الرقم المؤكد هذا الرقم لاننا عندما
يعني واذا انتظرنا الساعات ولم تدخل فرق
الانقاذ سوف يتضاعف الرقم وهناك
مناطق
كبيره وقرى لم تصل اليها الفرق
دون ان يعلم فيهم احد في بعض القرى
والبلدات في الاراضي السوريه لا نظام ولا
امكانيه يعني فريق الدفاع المدني هل هو
بعشرات القلوب التركيه لديها الاف
المبتدئين وتطلب المساعده من المجتمع
الدولي ما بالك فريق الدفاع المدني الذي
عمل برفقه المدنيين في محاوله الانقاذ من
يتم انقذه وهذا الامر ينطبق على مناطق
النظام
العمل الاهلي كان اكثر من العمل الحكومي
بدرجات ودرجات والمتبرعين بجهودهم سواء
للانقاذ سواء من فرق الطبيه سواء من
المشاكل الخاصه لكن يعني قلت لها قبل ايام
بان السيارات اسعاف لا يوجد لديها وقود من
اجل الاستمرار باسعاف المدنيين في مناطق
النظام شكرا جزيلا لرامي عبد الرحمن مدير
المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان من القاهره
شكرا جزيلا لك
نزوحنا من نوع اخر تعرض له السوريون مره
اخرى بعد الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب سوريا
او شمال سوريا ليكون ملجاهم خيام نازحي
الحرب السوريه في محيطيات اللب
[موسيقى]
منى لم تختبري النزوح طوال السنوات الحرب
سوريا الا ان رعب الزلزال دفعها لهجر
منزلها المدمر لتلجا الى من يشاركها
الماساه باختلاف الدافع
منى والعديد ممن نجوا من الزلزال المدمر
الذي ضربت تركيا وسوريا
ستجدوا بنازح الحرب في ادلب ليحتموا في
خيامهم جلال عندهم ناجحين وعرفوا
الله هيك بعدهم وحنان علينا واعطونا اغراض
من عندهم
زلزال القرن فاجا السكان في وقت باكرا من
الصباح ليهربوا من منازلهم بملابس النوم
حفاه مشهد مرعب عشه هذا الاب مع اطفاله
الاربعه حصل يعني صعبك جدا جدا يعني
كانه يوم القيامه يعني شغله كبيره كتير
وقعت البنايه
وهز قويه كتير كتير طلعنا حفيانين
بالرومات وبالمي والمطر يعني وضع صعب جدا
جدا
نازحوا الحرب الهاربون من القصف ومدافع
النظام السوري احتضن النازحين الجدد فقد
اشتركوا في خراب المنازل والرعب من الموت
بقى احنا سوينا اللي علينا جمعنا بعض
هالنساء بعضها الاطفال جبناها لعنا على
الخيام طلعنا برات خيامنا وحطيناهم
وسوينا اللي علينا يعني لفيناهم دفيناهم
ما بين طلع الضوء
تعددت الاسباب والموت واحد لتكون الخيام
جامعه المصائب السوريه ان كانت بفعل
الطبيعه او الانسان واحتمال النجاه الضعيف
اذا عمر العربيه
من القامش لمراسل العربيه جمعه عكاش جمعه
اهلا بك هل من حصيله دائما ما نسال عن
الارقام اولا ومن ثم ضعني في تفاصيل
الصوره لديك
صباح الخير عادل لك والاستعداد
الاخرين نعم هناك حصيله تتجدد للاسف
الشديد في مرور الساعات وليس بمرور الايام
هناك حوالي 3350 شخص فقدوا حياتهم في هذا
الزلزال الاعداد في مناطق المعارضه ارتفعت
الى 2100 بينما في مناطق النظام
1250 حتى هذه اللحظات
لبلده جنديرس النصيب الاكبر من هذه
الارقام بلده صغيره في ريف عفرين عادل عدد
حسب المعلومات التي وصلتنا للتو عدد الذين
فارقوا حياتهم في هذه البلده الصغيره بلغ
الف شخص حتى الان علما ان فرق الانقاذ لم
تصل الا سوى الى 30 مبنى من اصل 84 مبنى
منهار في هذه البلده الصغيره ما يعني ان
العدد قد يرتفع بوتيره سريعه اليوم مع
الجهود رفع الانقاذ الى مباني اخرى في هذا
النهار نحن نتحدث عن 6350
في في سوريا هذا العدد لا يشمل الاعداد
التي تدخل من معبر الجثث التي تدخل من
معبر باب الهواء اليوم صباحا
نعم اليوم صباحا الى الارقام المحدثه حتى
الساعه الحاديه عشره ليلا بتوقيت سوريا
ليله امس بلغ عدد الجثث التي وصلت الى
معبر باب
الهوى من الطرف التركي لسوريين فقدوا
حياتهم في زلزالي تركيا داخل في الولايات
العشره في تركيا الجثث التي دخلت عبر معبر
باب السلامه وصلت الى 360 جثه ويتوقع ايضا
ان تصل يعني خلال الساعات القليله المقبله
السيارات محمله بجثث اخرى يعني يعتقد بان
هناك اكثر من 500
سوري قتلوا في الزلزال
كانوا في المدن التركيه المتضرره طيب اذا
كان بالامكان الزميل المصور يتحرك لنرى
هذا المخيم الذي انت فيه هل يقتنه من
تضرروا جراء الزلزال ام انه موجود حتى
الان احتياطيا فبالتالي اعطيني صوره اكثر
اذا تكرمت جمعه
هذا هذا
هذه القيم اقامتها الاداره الذاتيه
في مدينه القامشلي في ملعب انتفاضه 12
اذار كاجراء التحوطي في لو حدث حدثت زلازل
او هزات ارتداديه
وبالتالي في اليوم الاول عندما كان هناك
هزه يعني وصلت ارتدادات الهزه الثانيه الى
القامشلي وكل الناس خرجوا الى الشوارع وفي
الليله الكثير منهم بعثوا في هذه القيم
لانهم كانوا يخشون يعني العوده الى منازله
طبعا هذه واحده من اصل خمس
مراكز ايواء وقيمه في شمال شرف البلاد في
القامشلي وفي منبج في الرقه وايضا في بلده
ديرك اقصى شمال شرق البلاد اجراءات
التحوطيه في حال لو حدثت هزاد او اراد
السكان يعني
اللجوء الى هذه المراكز وفضلوا البقاء
فيها من البيوت هناك طبعا عدد كبير من
المدنيين ياتون الى هذه القيم خاصه في
فتره الليل اولئك الذين يذكرون في يعني
مساكن عموديه في الطوابق العليا طيب بودي
ان اسالك ايضا عن معبر باب الهوى الانباء
التي تردكم من هناك هل دخلت مساعدات من
هذا المعبر ام فقط يتم الحديث عنه من دخول
بصهاريج تسعه يوم امس واليوم قد تدخل ايضا
خمسه صهاريج محمله بالوقود فقط او المازوت
عادل يعني هذه الصهاريج المحمله بالوقود
طبعا المطلوبه للغايه لان فرق الانقاذ
تعتمد في تشغيل مولداتها على المحروقات
لكن غير ذلك لم يدخل اي شيء حتى هذه
اللحظات لكن من المرتقب ان تصل الشحنات من
عده الدول وايضا من عده منظمات عبر معبر
باب الهوى اعتبارا من منتصف هذا النهار
الجسر الجوي الذي اعتمدته المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وصلت بعض الطائرات الى مطار اضنه
هناك ايضا طائرات من دول عربيه اخرى وصلت
الى مطار غازي عنتاب يعني اعتقد الكل
يحتاج الى بعض الوقت وبعض التنسيق مع
الطرف الى الطريق سالكه نعملها طريق سالكه
الى هذا المعبر وفق تاكيدات شهود عيان
وايضا وفاه التاكيدات يعني المعبر من
الجانب السوري يعني عادل نحن نتحدث عن
عشرات السيارات التي اقلت الجثث الى هذا
المعبر كيف يمكن للسيارات نقل الجثث ان
تصل ولي سيارات المساعدات تصل المساله
كانت من قبل المنظمات هي عباره عن يعني
الاستثمار في الوقت
تقييم الاحتياجات على الارض والحصول على
الموافقات اللازمه لادخال هذه هي
المساعدات شكرا جزيلا لمراسل العربيه جمعه
كاش من القامشلي
اذا الحصيله في تزايد
16,400 قتيل لاجراء هذا الزلزال الذي ضرب
سوريا وتركيا ينضم الينا من اسطنبول جواد
لوك الباحث في الشان التركي سيد جواد يعني
هل من تحديث للارقام اولا ومن ثم بودي ان
اسالك عن معبر باب الهوى واللغط الذي يدور
حوله
العدد الاخير
1273 الان الاخبار
اخبار على الاقل يعني تعطينا امل هل من
ناجين هل استخراج عدد من الناجين من تحت
الانقاذ في مختلف الولايات التركيه نعم
استخراج موجوده الان في مختلف المدن كما
تفضلت انه حتى بعد سبعين ساعه سبعه وسبعين
ساعه من الزلزال يخرجون
العالقين تحت الانغاظ بالنسبه الى العدد
بصراحه انا الان يعني في هذه الساعات خرجت
من
اعداد اكثر بكثير من هذه الاعداد التي
يذكر يعني الى الان توجد قرى ومحلات التي
لم تدخل فرق الانقاذ بصراحه العدد يزداد
مع الاسف الشديد لماذا لماذا لا تدخل فرق
الانقاذ اليها لان المساحه
واردا يعني
عشرتكم الاتراك نحن ما كنا
متهيئين لمثله هذه الكارثه بهذا بهذه
الوسعه يعني كانت الهزات سابقا في مدينه
مدينتين لكن الان عشره مدن بالنسبه يعني
اعلم انه من ديار بكر الى كهرمان مرعش او
او هذه المسافه الكبيره لم تكن جاهزه
تركيا ولكن تركيا ليس اول زلزال تمر فيه
وبالتالي ايضا هناك مناطق مدربه لديها
طواقم مدربه لماذا لا تستطيع الوصول وكيف
يتم التعامل مع هذه المدن لماذا مدن تصلها
المساعده وموديلات نعم اذكر لكم مثال انه
في حين الانقاذ
العالقين تحت الارض نرى تاتي هزات
ارتداديه ليس بارتداديه اصلا هزات جديده
كبيره جدا اكثر من ست نقطه سته فاصل سته
وغير ذلك
يهرب من المنطقه بشكل عام او يوقفون في
بعض المناطق بسبب ظروف القاسيه للشتاء
المروحيات لا تقدر تهبط او تقلع وهذه
المشاكل موجوده مع الاسف الظروف صعبه جدا
في بعض المناطق بالنسبه الى باب الهواء
الان جاءت تصريح من
وزير الخارجيه باب الهوى الان مفتوح ما
بين الاخرين ايضا نسعى للفتح حتى تصل
المساعدات الدوليه هذه هي كسرها الاخيره
التي جاءت من
لم تصل للمساعدات الدوليه سيد جواد
لايصال مساعدات الدوليه الى ما بين
الاخرين تصل المساعدات لكن حاجه كبيره
يعني نحن نعرف ان اشقائنا العربي
الاوروبيون يرسلون لكن لا يكفي لانه
صدقوني الناس
الى خبز الى الماء الشرب بس يعني
مشاكل كبيره حاجات الاوليه ايضا يحتاجون
اعلم اعلم ان المساحه كبيره ولكن دعني
ايضا ان اتساءل كيف تتعامل الحكومه
التركيه مع هذه الكارثه بانه بعض المناطق
لربما تكون مناطق بعيده عن مراكز المدينه
تعرضت لكن الى الان الحديث كما ذكرت حضرتك
ايضا انه لم تصلها فرق الانقاذ ولم يتم
التعامل معها حتى بعد 77 ساعه
نعم بصراحه يعني
الساحه فيها عرقله يعني مشاكل كثيره جدا
لكن الكل يسعى هنا يعني الحكومه ايضا تسعى
ان ارى ان رايت في الطرق ماكينات كبيره
شاحنات ممتلئه مؤسسات المجتمعات المدنيه
بلديات يشتغلون بقوه لكن كما قلت انغاز
مثلا في بعض المناطق اذا تريد تدخل البيوت
تنهار في نفس اللحظه في ثلاثه ثواني اربع
ثواني ينزل يسقط المباني بشكل غريب جدا
هزات الارتداديه اخطر ولهذا سبب حتى فرق
الانغايت لا يقدر ان يصلون الى بعض هذا في
خبر عاجل اصول البعثه السعوديه المشاركه
في اغاثه متضرري الزلزال الى تركيا كيف
يتم تقسيم هكذا مساعدات سواء مساعدات
عينيه او حتى فرق الانقاذ التي تصل يعني
اليوم احنا من السعوديه من
من تونس من دول اوروبيه حتى والصين ايضا
كيف يتم توزيعهم اذا اذا بالاضافه لمسانده
الفرق التركيه كيف يتم توزيعهم وبالتالي
اين القصور
مسكره من كانه صار فوضى في
اليومين الاولاني محلات للبيع السوبر
ماركتات صارت فوضى يعني الناس بخوف من
الجوع يعني يهاجموا الى هناك مسار فوضى
لكن بشكل عام الان صار شيئا ما من التنظيم
الكل الان يعني لا يوجد جوعان لكن برد
شديد بحاجه الى خيمه فقط خيمه لا يوجد لان
الناس خرجوا من منازلهم صدقوني لا يوجد
مبنى سالم في مدينه انطاكيا التي انا رايت
الكل خرجوا باقي في خارج البيوت لا يقدرون
بعضهما هاجروا الى قرى لكن لا تصل مساعدات
الى قرى لكن مؤسسات المجتمعات المدنيه قد
يصل الى هنا وهناك سيد سيد جواد يعني حتى
نفهم الاليه في هذه التوزيع وبالتالي
معالجه هذه الك
الان يعني بالنسبه في المرحله الاولى
بالنسبه الى مناطق سهل الوصول
خرجوا اطباء والفرق المشكله الاساسيه نعم
77 مستشفى منقل مؤقت بنوا كما صرحت
الحكومه التركيه رايت سيارات اسعاف كثيره
جدا والناس متعاملين لكن المناطق التي
سهله للوصول هم يصلون الى هناك بعض
الاماكن كما قلت يعني ندخل ترى ان المباني
في اي لهجه تقدر تهبط لا يقدر احد
يقترب من هناك في داخل المدينه في مركز
المدينه في مراكز المدينه مدن لا يستطيعون
الوصول الى الجيم فكيف في القرى
صعوبات كثيره جدا لا ولكن الكل يسعى حكومه
وشعب والحمد لله وصلوا الى نتائج ملموسه
لكن غير كافيه بصراحه نعم شكرا جزيلا
للسيد جواد جوكا الباحث في
التركي شكرا جزيلا لك
نعم
للاسف لم اسمع ما قلت سيد جواد في اخر
حديثك شكرا جزيلا لك كما ذكرنا قبل قليل
لوصلت الى مطار اضنه فرق الانقاذ والاسعاف
السعوديه وذلك ضمن جسرين جوي اعلنت
المملكه عن اطلاقه
واغاثه متضرري الزلزال في سوريا وتركيا
قبل ذلك افاد مراسل العربيه بان طائرتين
سعوديتين اتجهت الى مطار اضنه التركي
محملتين بمساعدات طبيه واغافيه وعلامتها
ايضا فرق اسعاف وانقاذ متخصصه مراسل
العربيه اضاف ان الجسر الجويه سيستمر خلال
الفتره المقبله ياتي ذلك فيما بلغ حجم
التبرعات داخل السعوديه
للمتضررين من الزلزال في سوريا وتركيا الى
اكثر من ثمانين مليون ريال
الى ذلك اعلنت منظمه الصحه العالميه انها
ستقوم بنشر فرق من خبراء الانقاذ وسترسل
الامدادات طبيه الى تركيا وسوريا
انها كارثه كبيره انتشر اثرها على نطاق
جغرافي واسع لدينا الكثير من الناجين الان
في العراق في ظروف سيئه للغايه لدينا
اضطرابات كبيره في امدادات المياه وانقطاع
في الوقود والكهرباء ووسائل الاتصالات
واساسيات الحياه هناك خطر حقيقي لحدوث
كارثه ثانويه قد تتسبب في ضرر لعدد اكبر
من الاشخاص من الكارثه الاوليه اذا لم
نتحرك بنفس الوتيره كما نفعل الان في
البحث والانقاذ
قال وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انطونيو
بلانك ان حجم الخسائر في الارواح جراء
الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا صادم ومروع
حقا وذكر ان الولايات المتحده نشرت اكثر
من 150 من عناصر البحث والانقاذ في تركيا
وان واشنطن سيكون لديها المزيد لتعلنه في
الايام المقبله بشان الكيفيه التي ستواصل
بها
دعم الشعبين التركي والسوري خلال مرحله
التعافي من الدمار
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله على السلامه
الحمد لله على السلامه يا محمد
في الاردن اقامت عائلات سوريه لاجئه بيت
عزاء بعد فقدانها الامل بالعثور على احد
عشر شخصا من اقاربها مازالوا تحت الانقاب
عائله المحاميد تقاسمت اللجوء بين الاردن
وتركيا هربا من الموت الذي كان بالمرصاد
لمن لجا منها لتركيا اثر كارثه الزلزال
هي اصعب لحظات الانتظار لحظات يفقد فيها
الامل انقطعت اخبار اهلهم في تركيا تحت
الانقاض بعد رساله من احدهم هناك وكانها
اللقاء الاخير وما بين العزاء والمواساه
تنتظر عائله المحاميد مصير احد عشر شخصا
من اقاربها ما زالوا تحت الركام
بطني في خشب ما يحسن اتحرك ورجليه ايدي ما
اشي
يلا ساعدنا ونقول غير رب العالمين يساعدنا
وما بعرف اذا بعيش ولا بموت نداء الحياه
هذا لم يكن الاخير تم انقاذ احمد اما مصير
اهله مازال مجهولا حتى بات الامل يضيق مع
مرور الوقت اذا عشر شخص عندنا لا نعلم اي
مصير عنهم هل هم احياء اموات
ما بنعرف بس الكلام والواقع او الشكل
انه رحمه الله عليهم في كان بعض الاصوات
تصدر من بين الركام ومنبرك هذا بنشد جميع
المنظمات مسانده اهلي برفع الانقاذ عن
عائلتي بستنى امل لسه انه يكون في حدا
منهم طالع حدا منهم ينجح لانه لحتى الان
هم تحت الانقاذ بسالهم ثلاث ايام يعني انت
تتخيل بنايه سبع طوابق
وثلاث ايام وهم محشوقين شو بده يصير فيهم
المنا ما حصل لنا في 12 عاما
ونحن
نعاني الان اكثر واكثر بالكارثه التي حصلت
ونفقد الان
عائله كامله من 11 شخص
وهذه والله مصيبه عائله سوريه لاجئه تبكي
حال اهلها في تركيا فخيط الحياه التي
تمسكوا به كان رفيعا سرعان ما انقطع بعدما
هربوا من موت لموت اكبر لاجئين ولكن تحت
الركام من مدينه الرمثا شمال العاصمه عمان
عماد العضايله العربيه
لبنان لبنان له حصه في هذه الكارثه ضحايا
ومفقودون هاجروا بحثا عن حياه افضل من
ازمات بلادهم لينالوا نصيبهم من زلزال
تركيا ابراهيم خلف وزوجته واولاده الثلاثه
من طرابلس في شمال لبنان لا يزالون في
عداد المفقودين على حدود انطاكيا والعائله
تتوسل اي خبر عن مصيرهم
وكان قدر اللبنانيين ان يتشاركوا كوارث
العالم باجمعه فعدد منهم في عداد الضحايا
او المفقودين جراء الزلزال المدمر نحن في
منزل عائله ابراهيم خلف المفقود وعائلته
في تركيا
مرحبا
عيون العائلات تراقب بدقه كل تفصيل على
نشرات الاخبار علها تلمح وجوه ابراهيم
وزوجته واولاده الثلاثه بين الناجين مع كل
عمليه انقاذ يشاهدونها على الشاشات
انا شجعته ايه والله
بحس مرات هيك قلبي بقلي بكونوا متخبين
بشيء
بس اسمع هيك بيقمت قلبي بصير
قبل ساعات من الزلزال كان حديث هاتفي مطول
بين ابراهيم ووالدته
اكثر من ثلاث ارباع ساعه احكي
لي على الوضع هونيك هو مبسوط صارت بالليل
طلع الزلزال اجيت اتصلت ما حدا رد عليه
الوضع الاقتصادي المتدهور في لبنان هو ما
دفع بهذه العائله الى الهجره قبل حوالي
اربعه اشهر تواصلنا مع الخارجيه حتى اليوم
رجعنا تواصلنا معهم مره ثانيه اخذوا
اللوكيشن البيت تبعه
والاسم المنطقه واخذوا اسمائهم والصور
وقالوا لنا خليكم على السماء انه ان شاء
الله يكون حس على بدايه الزلزال انه قدر
طلع من البيت كونه البيت كثير صغير يعني
البنايه الف من ثلاث طوابق هو بالطابق
الثاني يعني الخروج منها بكون سهل كثير
فنتمنى انه يكون حس على الزلزال وطلع لبرا
هو المنشور الاخير الذي نشرته العائله
المفقوده على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي قبل
يوم واحد من الزلزال وتضرعات العائله بان
يتبعه منشور اخر يزف سلمتهم نهج يوسف
العربيه بيروت
يبحث الكثير من الاتراك والسوريين
المغتربين عن اقاربهم في مناطق الزلزال
والذين ما زالوا مفقودين من بينهم احمد
باي من انطاكيا الذي يعيش في برلين ويقضي
ايامه منذ الزلزال في محاوله الاتصال
باقاربه بحثا عن العشرات من الاصدقاء
والاهل في المقام الاول
السلام عليكم خيو
كيفكم
شفتوا خالتي شي ولا لا
صعبه
منذ ان دمر الزلزال قريه احمد بيه في
انطاكيا وهو يقضي معظمه وقته بالاتصال بمن
يمكن بحثا عن عشره المفقودين من اصدقائه
وعائلته من بينهم خالته من محله في منطقتي
كريت باك واسط برلين يعني بنت عمي وحده
منهم
وخالتي هلا راحوا يدوروا عليها واصحابي
يعني كتير هلا اغلبيه اصحابنا ضخم من
الخوار هذا
على هاتفه صوره بلدته المدمره وابني خالته
الذي يبحث عن والدته بين الركام
ين يعني هلا قبل شوي حكيت مع عمي
يعني كل يوم عم يجي الجنازات كلهم
عم ندفنونه هيك يعني البلده يقول احمد
تركت بمفردها منذ يوم زلزال ولم يكن قد
وصل اليها لا مسعفون ولا مساعدات لحد هلا
ما حدا بس كل واحد لحاله
يعني كيف يعني شو بيطلع بايدهم
ان يسافر الى تركيا ليساعد عائلته ولكنه
غير واثق النمته وكيف يمكنه الوصول وسط
الضمائر المحيطي ببلدته راغب بهنام
العربيه برلين
هو سباق مع الزمن وامل لمن يترقب المساعده
لانقاذ المنكوبين بان لا تكون موازين
السياسه اهم من حياه البشر ربما صرخه طفل
او النداء استغاثه من تحت الركام يوقف
عداد الموت المتزايد بين لحظه واخرى اذا
ساعدنا الاخباريه انتهت لكن تغطيه العربيه
مستمره على مدار الساعه الان ننتقل الى
استديوهاتنا في الرياض وزميل احمد الهادي
حيث سيكون معكم على مدار الساعه